Reto möchte von den Drogen wegkommen.
Zum elften Mal geht er in die Klinik
für einen kontrollierten Entzug.
460.
400 und dann noch 60.
Wieder zu Hause, möchte er
erst einmal Ordnung schaffen.
Das Problem ist, dass es nur
ein Entzug von der Substanz war.
Aber in meinem Innern
hat sich nicht so viel geändert.
Samira kämpft mit ihrer Fitnesssucht
und einer Essstörung.
Auch sie ist in die Klinik gegangen.
Ich möchte weiterhin Sport treiben,
aber mit einem anderen Bezug,
damit es kein Zwang
und keine Sucht mehr ist.
Cahit ist spielsüchtig und hat
einen schweren Rückfall hinter sich,
bei dem er das ganze Geld
von der Sozialhilfe verspielt hat.
Das war das Geld für Dezember?
- Ja, genau.
Also haben Sie
über Weihnachten kein Geld? - Ja.
Mit einer Reise
möchte er seinem Umfeld entkommen
und offene Rechnungen begleichen.
Sie alle wollen eine Veränderung -
weg von der Sucht
und in ein neues Leben.
Nach einem Monat in der Klinik findet
Reto zu Hause das alte Chaos vor.
Ich sollte eben gar nicht mehr
solchen Müll anhäufen.
Seit er 16 war,
hatte er verschiedene Drogenprobleme.
Das hat sich
mit den Jahren angesammelt.
Mir ist nicht mehr wohl ...
... in dieser Unordnung.
Im Moment ist er clean.
Da bekommt man ja Depressionen.
Es herrschte wirklich
eine Riesenunordnung.
Also unordentlich ist es immer noch.
Es ist schwierig.
Eigentlich
kann ich alles noch gebrauchen.
Es liegt einfach nicht ordentlich
auf dem Tisch, aber jetzt ...
Jetzt steht dafür dieser Sack
in der Gegend herum.
* Gähnen *
Jetzt möchte Reto
unbedingt wieder arbeiten.
Hallo, Renato.
Ja, es geht.
Merci. Einen schönen Tag.
Ade, Renato.
Wer war das?
Die Fassadenbau-Montage.
Hast du einen Job?
Ja, aber nur temporär.
Das wusste ich gar nicht.
Ich habe auch soeben davon erfahren.
Aber Fassadenbau-Montage
ist verdammt anstrengend.
Er meinte, das komme gut,
weil ich es schon kenne.
Aber ob es gut kommt,
ist nicht nur abhängig von mir.
Aber es ist doch cool,
dass du einen Einstieg hast, nicht?
Das heisst gar nichts, temporär.
Guten Morgen!
Wie ihr sehen könnt,
habe ich mir hier viele Merkzettel
an den Kühlschrank
und die Küchenschränke geheftet.
Die Essattacken
sind immer noch ein Thema.
Es ist
sehr, sehr viel besser geworden,
aber es ist nach wie vor ein Thema,
das sehr belastend für mich ist,
weil es einen grossen Einfluss auf
meinen Körper und meine Psyche hat.
Und das alles führt dazu,
dass ich mich noch schlechter fühle,
wenn ich nicht trainiere, etc. etc.
Es ist das übliche Karussell,
das noch nicht vollständig ...
Entschuldigung.
... noch nicht vollständig
aufgehört hat.
Samira war bis vor Kurzem
wegen ihrer Fitnesssucht
und einer Essstörung in der Klinik.
Heute besucht sie ihre Gotte,
eine ihrer engsten Vertrauten.
Du bist ja schon da!
- Ja. Hoi.
Hoi, Samira. Salü.
- Hoi, hoi.
Geht's gut?
- Ja. Und selber?
Auch, danke.
Ich komme gerade vom Training.
Wolltest du das Weisse?
- Nein.
Neben
den regelmässigen Therapiegesprächen
sind die Treffen mit ihrer Gotte
wichtig für Samira.
Schön, bist du wieder mal da.
Klar, ich habe vieles
in den Griff bekommen.
Aber die nächtlichen Essattacken,
die sehr unregelmässig vorkommen,
habe ich nicht im Griff.
Das passiert
vielleicht einmal die Woche.
Das ist für mich immer noch zu viel.
Ich möchte das loswerden,
weiss aber nicht, wie.
Ja, ich glaube,
es ist nichts Einfaches,
was du da durchmachen musst.
Ich denke auch sehr oft,
ich habe versagt.
Ich frage mich auch, was ich anders
machen könnte, woran es liegt.
Wie geht es deinem Bauch
nach dem Essen?
Ist es schlimmer geworden?
Nein,
ich esse auch nicht mehr endlos.
Das ist es nicht.
Ich esse auch keine Unmengen.
Das konnte ich ...
- Immerhin etwas.
Ja, ich habe Fortschritte gemacht.
Aber langsam fehlt mir die Geduld.
Denn irgendwann ...
Ich bin so stolz auf dich.
Ich finde, du machst das sehr gut.
Ich habe gesehen,
wie es früher mit dem Essen war.
Da hat sie sich wirklich geschadet.
Damals war es wirklich sehr schlimm.
Und das sehe ich jetzt nicht mehr.
Ich sehe aber auch,
dass sie ziemlich abgenommen hat.
Sie ist schlanker geworden.
Jetzt weiss ich nicht,
ob sie genug isst.
Das weiss ich nicht.
Oder zu viel macht?
Ja ...
* Schräge Klänge *
Samira trainiert wieder oft,
manchmal mehrmals täglich.
Sie definiert sich immer noch
stark darüber, wie sie aussieht,
über ihren fitten Körper.
Vor einem halben Jahr hattest du
das Gefühl, du seist fitnesssüchtig.
Das bin ich
wahrscheinlich immer noch.
Ich habe aber einfach auch gemerkt,
dass es ein Teil von mir ist.
Schon vor einem halben Jahr
sagte ich,
dass ich es nicht aufgeben werde.
Ich möchte aber
einen anderen Bezug dazu bekommen.
Das habe ich auch geschafft.
Bzw. habe ich auch gemerkt,
dass ich es nicht aufgeben muss.
Andere spielen auch fünfmal
die Woche Fussball oder Volleyball.
Im Training fühle ich mich sicher.
Im Training weiss ich,
was ich zu tun habe
und was ich kann.
Das regelmässige Fitnesstraining
gibt Samira eine Struktur.
Sie hat immer noch keinen Job
und lebt
von der Krankentaggeldversicherung.
Im Moment weiss ich nicht,
wie es weitergeht.
Das ist für mich ein Zustand,
den ich kaum aushalte.
Ich will vorwärtsmachen,
ich will wieder ...
Ich will wieder einen Lichtblick -
doch den habe ich im Moment nicht.
Das verlieh mir bzw. verleiht mir
ein schlechtes Gefühl.
Samira
ist gelernte Hochbauzeichnerin.
Sie will nicht zurück in ihren Beruf.
* Gemächliche Gitarrenklänge *
Heute beginnt Reto zu arbeiten.
Ich bin ein verdammter Morgenmuffel.
Geht die noch richtig?
Ich staune selbst über mich.
Ich bin noch
keine zwei Wochen zu Hause.
Seit dem Klinikaustritt.
Ich weiss nicht, ob ich von null
auf hundert durchstarten kann.
Ich würde gerne noch pennen,
ehrlich gesagt.
Wie viel Uhr haben wir?
- 10 vor.
Also.
Sein Arbeitsort: eine Metallbaufirma,
die viele temporäre Arbeiter braucht.
Guten Morgen.
- (Alle) Guten Morgen.
Gefragt ist einfach Genauigkeit.
Meter oder Zentimeter
sind für uns kein Mass,
wir bewegen uns
im Millimeterbereich.
Das sollte kein Problem sein, oder?
- Ich denke nicht.
Eine zweite Chance
ist wichtig, nicht?
Das ist ...
Jeder hat zuweilen
eine zweite Chance verdient.
Willst du mal probieren?
- Ja.
Ich würde die Niete hier
reinstecken. Dann geht's einfacher.
Durchdrücken!
Reto ist gelernter Metallbauer,
hat aber schon lange
nicht mehr als solcher gearbeitet.
Jetzt warst du extrem schief.
Schau, dass du etwas gerade bist!
- Ja.
Zuerst noch die Bolzen.
Aber das kommt mit der Zeit.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Cahit ist spielsüchtig
und leidet unter Depressionen.
Er zockt am Handy in Online-Casinos
oder schliesst Sportwetten ab.
Die Sucht hat ihn einsam gemacht.
Er hat Geldsorgen, keinen Job -
und dennoch spielt er weiter.
Was ist die Faszination
dieser Spiele?
Mit Zocken Geld zu machen.
Die Faszination ist, Geld zu machen?
- Mhm.
In den letzten Jahren
hat er über 100'000 Fr. verspielt.
Du sagtest ja, es wäre cool,
jetzt einfach aufzuhören.
Ja.
Aber du konntest es
nicht ganz sein lassen.
Nein, im Moment ist es schwierig,
ganz aufzuhören.
V.a. wenn man nichts zu tun hat,
keine Beschäftigung hat.
Er ist 46 Jahre alt und möchte
sein Leben schon lange aufräumen.
Vor wenigen Tagen hatte er in einem
Internetcafe einen schweren Rückfall.
Er hat sein gesamtes Geld von der
Sozialhilfe verspielt: rund 800 Fr.
Aber heute rafft er sich auf.
Nach Wochen besucht er
wieder einmal die Therapie.
* Schräge Klänge *
Grüezi, Frau Bekes. Guten Tag.
- Guten Tag, kommen Sie!
Alles,
was ich am Freitag bekommen habe,
habe ich noch am selben Tag
verspielt.
Ich habe knapp 800 Fr. bekommen
und habe alles verspielt.
Das Problem ist,
dass ich nicht aufhören kann.
Zwar bin ich zwischenzeitlich
mit 800-1'000 Fr. im Plus,
trotzdem kann ich nicht aufhören.
Das war das Geld für Dezember?
- Ja, genau.
Also haben Sie
über Weihnachten kein Geld? - Ja.
Geldsorgen
sind Cahits grosses Problem.
Bei ihm zu Hause
stapeln sich die Rechnungen,
die er nicht bezahlen kann.
Ich habe offene Rechnungen,
Polizeibussen ...
Wenn ich nicht
termingerecht bezahle,
muss ich fünf Tage einsitzen.
Im Gefängnis?
- Ja.
Wenn er nicht bald bezahlt,
muss er ins Gefängnis.
Das ist schon dramatisch.
- Ja.
Hat Frust dazu geführt?
Sie haben gesehen,
dass es wenig Geld ist.
Sie müssen noch Rechnungen bezahlen.
Und dann ist bei Ihnen -
salopp gesagt -
eine Sicherung durchgebrannt,
und sie sind zocken gegangen.
Ist das so gewesen?
Ja, genau.
Man dreht richtiggehend durch.
In den nächsten Tag
will man nichts von der Welt wissen.
Irgendwie ...
Und wenn Sie Wut verspüren,
was machen Sie?
Dann rauche ich einen Joint.
- Eben, ja.
Es ist natürlich nicht ideal,
wenn Sie dann
mit Ihren Kiffer-Freunden rumhängen
und dann wieder kiffen und trinken.
Schon bald ist Weihnachten.
Cahit hat nichts vor,
auf das er sich freuen könnte.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Etwa zur selben Zeit
am Weihnachtsmarkt.
Das Essensangebot
stellt Samira auf die Probe.
Sie ist
mit ihrer besten Freundin unterwegs.
Ich bin noch sehr unschlüssig.
- Zwischen?
Etwas Asiatischem, Salat ...
Du magst es doch scharf?
- Nein, das mag ich nicht.
Für mich gerne das Poulet.
Immer nur drauf damit!
Nein, Käse mag ich nicht.
- Wolltest du nicht?
Hauptsache,
er fragt dich und nicht mich.
Sie überlegt sich immer noch ganz
genau, was sie isst und was nicht.
Am besten ist das Fladenbrot.
- Voll für nichts!
Natürlich denke ich
noch immer darüber nach.
Ich würde jetzt z.B.
keine Bratwurst essen.
Das ist für mich wie ...
Keine Ahnung.
Es muss etwas Richtiges sein.
Etwas Richtiges
heisst etwas Gesundes?
Ja, Gemüse, Fleisch
und Kohlenhydrate müssen dabei sein.
Und nicht übermässig viel ...
Nicht nur Fett.
- Nicht nur Fett, genau.
Ausserhalb der Klinik
ist Samira wieder selbst für sich
und ihre Ernährung verantwortlich.
Oh ja, wirklich heiss.
Sie muss wieder selber überlegen,
was und wann sie isst,
ob sie sich
etwas gönnen möchte oder nicht.
Dass ich mir nicht alles verbiete,
sondern die Balance,
die ich jetzt habe, behalte.
Machen wir ein Selfie?
- Ja.
Gut.
- Ist gut?
* Vereinzelte,
akzentuierte Geigenklänge *
Nach einer Woche
ist Reto wieder auf Jobsuche.
Es hat nicht funktioniert
mit seinem Arbeitgeber.
Arbeiten ist ziemlich anstrengend.
Wieso?
Einfach körperlich.
Die Platten sind verdammt schwer.
Er macht einen Schnitt,
du musst sie wieder kehren,
und die wiegen bestimmt 50-60 kg.
Natürlich
hebt man sie zu zweit an, aber ...
Er möchte einen anderen Job finden.
Ich arbeite gerne, aber ich bin
nicht irgendein Hilfsarbeiter.
Hast du keine Angst davor,
wenn du zu Hause sitzt,
dass du wieder ...
Doch, natürlich.
Sicher.
Das ist aber nicht
seine einzige Sorge.
Er muss noch
eine hohe Busse bezahlen.
Weil ich Gras
und ein paar Pilze dabei hatte.
Und einen Schlagring.
Sie haben mich damit erwischt,
als ich jemandem
etwas schenken wollte.
Ich wollte nichts verkaufen.
3'200 Kröten, Mann!
Das kannst du niemals bezahlen, oder?
Jedenfalls nicht auf einmal.
Und was sind die Optionen?
Ratenzahlung.
Abarbeiten.
Das habe ich schon eingeleitet.
Ja.
So, jetzt.
Reto entscheidet sich
fürs Abarbeiten.
Bei der Felber-Stiftung in Bern
muss er ran.
* Pfeifen, Bohrgeräusche *
Es ist einfach langweilig,
den ganzen Tag
diesen Scheiss zusammenzuschrauben.
Trotzdem lernst du
jeden Tag etwas Neues.
Echt?
- Ich schon.
Echt? Immer noch?
Die Leute sind in Ordnung,
damit hat es nichts zu tun.
Aber die Arbeit ist scheisse.
Es ist das kleinere von zwei Übeln.
Wir müssen da nicht
in die Details gehen.
Ja, ja.
Ihr bekommt auch eine Chance,
wenn ihr hier arbeitet.
Es ist ein kleiner, erster Schritt,
bevor es dann weitergeht.
Genau.
Es gibt ihnen auch eine Struktur.
Sie müssen morgens kommen,
sie müssen sich abmelden,
wenn sie nicht kommen können.
Es ist wirklich strukturiert.
Sie haben hier auch Gesellschaft,
sind nicht allein.
Für manche ist es wichtig,
dass sie nicht
allein zu Hause verharren müssen.
Aber die Arbeit ist einfach mühsam.
Ich kann es nicht anders sagen.
Für Reto ist es zwar eine Strafe,
aber eben auch eine Beschäftigung.
* Christliche Rockmusik *
Einmal die Woche
besucht Reto die Freikirche.
Die Leute dort gaben ihm in den
letzten schwierigen Jahren Halt.
Danke vielmals.
Wenn sich Menschen heimatlos fühlen,
dann wünsche und bete ich,
dass sie verwurzelt sein dürfen,
tief in Gott.
Gott begleitet uns
auf all unseren Wegen.
Mhm.
Er begleitet uns auch
auf unseren Irrwegen,
die kein gutes Ende nehmen, auf
denen wir Dinge in den Sand setzen.
Alle, die kommen ...
Alle sind wert...
... wertvolle Menschen, Geschöpfe
in den Augen Gottes. - Ja.
Wir wollen die Liebe,
die wir selbst erfahren haben,
und diese Annahme
und diese Gemeinschaft
einfach teilen
und einander eine Heimat geben.
Tschau, Ruedi. Eine schöne Woche.
Eine Umarmung gehört dazu.
- Das ist auch etwas Schönes.
Nach der Messe sitzt man zusammen.
Ich hätte einen Zopf
mitbringen können.
Einen selbst gemachten?
- Ja.
Das hätte mich gefreut.
- Echt?
Du siehst gut aus.
Du wirkst fit.
Das freut mich sehr.
Eine Zeit lang
warst du jeweils sehr müde.
Zusammen geht's immer einfacher.
* Sanfte Musik *
Das ist cool.
Bei Reto geht's langsam bergauf.
Auch Cahit verbringt
wieder mehr Zeit mit Freunden.
Er möchte sein Leben ändern.
Am liebsten
würde er als Chauffeur arbeiten,
aber er hat noch
keine einzige Bewerbung geschrieben.
Seinen Fahrausweis ist er los.
Seit seinem Absturz kifft er wieder -
auch mit seinem Kumpel John.
Seit zwei, drei Tagen
rauche ich einen Joint pro Tag.
Oder nehme zwei, drei Züge.
Meint sie einen Joint?
- Ja, ja.
Besser als Alkohol zu trinken.
Auch John
ist seit Jahren spielsüchtig.
Sie kochen ab und zu gemeinsam
und können offen
über ihre Probleme reden.
Wie siehst du
die Entwicklung von Cahit?
Er versucht vom Spielen wegzukommen,
wie schlägt er sich dabei?
Ja ...
Es ist sehr schwierig für ihn.
Zu schwierig?
- Ja.
Seit Jahren ist er drin ...
... in diesem Dschungel.
Seit ich ihn kenne,
seit fast 20 Jahren,
spielt er immer weiter,
weiter und weiter.
Beim gemeinsamen Essen
können beide sie selbst sein.
Das ist ihr Festessen
zur Weihnachtszeit.
Guten Appetit.
Sie wollen die Sorgen
für einen Moment vergessen.
Z.B. die Vorladung ins Gefängnis
wegen der Busse,
die Cahit nicht bezahlt hat.
Gehst du jetzt ins Gefängnis
oder bezahlst du die Busse?
Ich kann die Busse
mittlerweile bezahlen.
Bezahlst du sie wirklich?
- Ja.
Du willst nicht
einen Tag ins Gefängnis? - Nein.
Aber warum wartest du so lange,
du hattest doch Zahltag?
Ich bin knapp dran,
mit allem knapp dran.
Es hat keine Priorität?
- Nein.
Genau.
Cahit hat resigniert.
Am Schluss bettle ich bei
meinem Bruder oder meinen Eltern.
"Gib mir Geld!
Ich muss Bussen bezahlen."
Nicht betteln!
Ist es nicht problematisch,
wenn man mit Leuten zusammen ist,
die dieselben Probleme haben?
So wird man nicht gesund, oder?
- Es liegt an ihm.
Niemand anderes ist schuld.
Man ist selber schuld.
Er ist selber schuld.
Es ist niemand anderes schuld, oder?
- Ja.
Samira möchte das Kapitel Sucht
in ihrem Leben abschliessen.
Und das soll man
auf ihrem Körper sehen.
Geht's gut? Nervös?
- Ja.
Immer.
- (Lachend) Immer.
Das hat auch er gemacht -
und jetzt mache ich hier weiter.
Genau.
Das ist eine indianische Kriegerin
mit einem Bären auf dem Kopf.
Aufgrund
dieser ganzen Therapiegeschichte
ist es
der richtige Zeitpunkt für mich.
Quasi als Neuanfang.
Deshalb freue ich mich.
Die Kämpferin auf Samiras Arm
soll für sie selbst stehen
und für den Weg,
auf dem sie sich befindet.
Es gibt es immer ups and downs,
das ist völlig normal
Aber im grossen Ganzen ...
... merke ich,
dass ich auf dem richtigen Weg bin.
Es kommt langsam.
Ich bin gespannt und bereit für das,
was kommen wird.
Deshalb das Tattoo
mit der Kämpferin.
Ich kämpfe weiter, egal was kommt.
* Gemächliche Musik *
Cahit hat Glück:
Er muss nicht ins Gefängnis.
Seine Bussen hat er mit einem
Vorschuss des Sozialamts bezahlt.
Es regnet wirklich wie verrückt.
Aber auch in seiner alten Heimat,
der Türkei,
hat er noch offene Rechnungen.
Diese möchte er begleichen.
Das Geld dafür hat ihm
einmal mehr seine Familie gegeben.
In der Türkei hat Cahit
noch nie um Geld gespielt.
Dort hat er kein ungesundes Umfeld.
Sein Ziel:
Ich möchte etwas wegkommen
von diesen Kollegenkreisen,
wo alle Suchtprobleme haben.
Ich möchte von ihnen
etwas wegkommen.
Das tut mir vielleicht gut.
Wegen Alkohols am Steuer
musste er seinen
türkischen Fahrausweis abgeben.
Diese Busse muss er bezahlen,
sonst wird es teuer.
Ab sechs Monaten
verdoppelt sich der Betrag.
Wegen der Zinsen.
Es ist keine Mahngebühr
wie in der Schweiz.
Dort wird die Busse
gleich verdoppelt.
In Antalya in der Südtürkei
hat Cahit seit seiner Kindheit
immer wieder Ferien gemacht.
Diesmal ist Cahit aber nicht hier,
um Ferien zu machen
* Sie sprechen türkisch. *
Hier ist ja immer noch Sommer.
Auch in der Schweiz musste Cahit
seinen Fahrausweis abgeben.
Zuerst will er sich
den türkischen zurückholen -
eines nach dem anderen.
Der Führerausweis
ist ein grosser Vorteil.
Denn ich habe keine Ausbildung,
keine abgeschlossene Lehre -
und auch keine Arbeit.
Deshalb ist der Führerausweis
sehr wichtig für mich.
Aber zuerst geht's zum Zahnarzt -
auch das ist dringend nötig.
Guten Tag.
Ist der Zahnarzt gleich im Parterre?
Der Zahnarzt
ist in der Türkei viel günstiger.
Letzten Sommer liess Cahit hier
mehrere Kronen flicken.
Mein Unterkiefer
ist eine Katastrophe.
Es fehlen drei, vier Zähne.
Ich kann seit letztem Sommer
nicht mehr richtig essen.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Lange nicht mehr gesehen.
Oh, es ist etwa sechs Monate her.
Ich gebe mich ganz in Ihre Hände.
Ich tue, was ich kann.
Cahit erzählt, dass die drei
neuen Kronen vom letzten Sommer
nach zwei Wochen
in der Schweiz rausgefallen sind.
Cahits Zähne
sind in schlechtem Zustand.
In ein paar Jahren müssen vielleicht
noch mehr Zähne ersetzt werden.
Jetzt braucht er aber zunächst
neue Kronen und ein Zahnimplantat.
Dann sollte Cahit
auch wieder gut essen können.
In scha' Allah. In scha' Allah.
Samira ist mit ihren Freunden
in Flumserberg.
Ihre Freundin Julia beobachtet,
dass es Samira viel besser geht.
Sie ist viel lebensfroher.
Man merkt, dass sie sich
in ihrem Körper wohler fühlt.
Das strahlt sie auch aus.
Zeig mir mal dein neues Tattoo!
Noch nicht gesehen?
- Nein.
Du warst in den Ferien, du Lümmel!
Lümmel?
- Du Schlingel!
Zeig her!
Mega gross, nicht?
Es ist megacool geworden.
Ich habe sehr viel Freude daran.
Es ist noch nicht ganz verheilt,
aber ...
Das ist klar.
Wann hast du es gemacht?
Vor zwei Wochen.
- Ja, logisch.
Zu Mittag gibt's es ein Sandwich -
auch um zu sparen.
Samira muss aufs Geld achten.
Sie möchte endlich wieder einen Job.
Letzte Woche hatte sie
ihre ersten Vorstellungsgespräche -
als Fitnesscoach.
Viele werden jetzt
die Arme verwerfen:
"Wie kannst du das nur machen?"
Sportsüchtig und Essstörung
und dann in diesem Sektor arbeiten -
das scheint nicht zu passen.
Aber ich habe mir
viele Gedanken darüber gemacht.
Schon seit Jahren, seit ich
angefangen habe zu trainieren,
träume ich davon,
auf diesem Beruf zu arbeiten.
Wie ich diese Vision umsetze,
weiss ich ehrlich gesagt noch nicht.
Mein Wunsch ist es,
dass ich weitergeben kann,
was die Risiken sind,
die ich durchgemacht habe,
die negativen und Schattenseiten,
die aufgekommen sind,
und was ich daraus gelernt habe.
Ich wäre froh gewesen,
wenn ich vor vier Jahren
jemanden gehabt hätte,
der mich zwar unterstützt, aber
auch vor den Gefahren gewarnt hätte.
Yippie!
Ich wünsche mir nach wie vor noch
etwas mehr Frieden mit mir selbst.
Also, so ein bisschen ...
Ja, das ist es.
In der Altstadt von Antalya.
Hier schaute Cahit
letzten Sommer zu tief ins Glas.
Daraufhin erwischte ihn die Polizei,
und er musste seinen
türkischen Fahrausweis abgeben.
Wo genau bin ich
letzten Sommer gewesen?
Genau hier war ich letzten Sommer.
Hier bist du schon mal gewesen?
Ja, hier habe ich nachts
drei-, viermal gesoffen.
Damit möchte er abschliessen.
Seine Busse
hat er in der Zwischenzeit bezahlt.
Das kann Cahit heute feiern -
eine grosse Erleichterung für ihn.
Das kann ich
dann auch am Morgen abholen.
Mit dieser Quittung
bekommt er seinen Fahrausweis zurück.
Hast du jetzt geschafft,
was du dir vorgenommen hast?
Wenn man will,
kann man alles schaffen.
Es braucht einfach Willen.
Und man muss auch Ziele haben.
Ein Vorsatz, mit dem sich Cahit
auch in der Schweiz
den Fahrausweis zurückholen will.
* Sanfte,
leicht melancholische Musik *
Cahit sucht seinen Weg raus aus
der Sucht nach Online-Geldspielen.
Eine Sucht,
die ihm viel genommen hat.
Es ist verlorene Zeit.
Ich nahm 15 Jahre lang
nicht am Leben teil.
Er weiss, dass er dranbleiben muss.
Ganz geschafft hat er es noch nicht.
Von ganz
kann man noch nicht sprechen.
Die Heimreise in die Schweiz
gibt ihm zu denken.
Was bringt die Zukunft?
Das muss ich mir erkämpfen,
denke ich momentan.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
* Sanfte Klänge *
Drei Monate sind bei Reto vergangen.
Seither
hat er seine Busse abgearbeitet.
Bisher hatte er noch
keinen Rückfall in die Drogen.
Und:
Er ist auf E-Zigaretten umgestiegen.
Das hat einen Grund:
Es gibt jemanden,
der den Gestank gar nicht mag.
Reto hat eine Freundin.
Seit etwa drei Monaten.
Seit drei Monaten, ja.
Drei, vier ...
Wir kennen uns schon länger -
seit vier, fünf Monaten.
Aber seit drei Monaten
sind wir zusammen.
Eine Beziehung
bringt einen auf andere Gedanken.
Ja.
Stell dir vor!
Das ist schön, nicht?
Was?
- Und es ist auch schön, nicht?
Natürlich ist es schön.
Es ist jetzt
schon fast ein halbes Jahr
seit deinem Klinikaustritt vergangen.
Echt? Nein.
Mind. fünf Monate.
Fünf Monate, ja.
Wow, nicht schlecht!
Ja.
- Fünf Monate.
Und ich hatte
eigentlich keinen Absturz.
Und auch kein Verlangen, nicht?
Doch, doch,
das ist immer ein wenig vorhanden.
Ich hatte schon oft das Gefühl,
ich hätte es geschafft,
und bin wieder
auf die Schnauze gefallen.
Jetzt braucht er nur noch eine
feste Anstellung zu seinem Glück.
* Sanfte Musik *
So?
Manchmal platze ich fast vor Lachen.
Ich habe wirklich Freude am Leben
und bin sehr zufrieden,
wie es momentan läuft.
Klar, ich habe keinen Job,
aber die Hoffnung ist da,
dass ich mit allem aufhören
und wieder zu einem normalen Leben
zurückfinden kann.
Hello again!
Ich habe gestern eine Zusage
für eine megacoole Stelle erhalten.
Ja, ich bin im Moment
einfach sehr glücklich.